. We are now we've already gone through today
the false claims that wind turbines are responsible
for the power outages in Texas.
That's not true.
While some with wind turbines did freeze,
wind is responsible for a small portion of
Texas energy, particularly at this time of
year.
The primary issue was frozen instruments at
unprepared, not weather proofed, a nuclear
natural gas and coal power plants, energy
generation plants.
Now, not only were we aware for a long time
that you should be prepared for cold weather
even in parts of the country that typically
don't have it, because that's what climate
science models predict, warming overall on
the planet with increasingly erratic weather,
individual weather events in different places.
But 10 years ago, Texas had this issue.
And there's a very interesting op ed in the
Fort Worth Star Telegram out of Texas, which
points out public and private sector leaders
may try to say there's no way they could have
been prepared for this.
That's a line of bull that no Texans should
accept.
This is an op ed from yesterday or today.
In 2011, Texas had what is known as the epic
storm that ruined the Super Bowl in Arlington.
And agencies at all levels offered recommendations
to address the problems that contributed to
those outages and that none of the recommendations
are not nearly enough and not a sufficient
amount of the recommendations were actually
taken.
This was compiled into a report a decade ago.
The report is called was called Report on
Outages and Curtailments during the Southwest
cold weather event of February one through
five, 2011.
Causes and recommendations.
And that report pinpointed exactly where things
went wrong, how to ensure that it didn't happen
again in the future.
Many of the measures that were recommended
were not particularly expensive and they were
not particularly difficult to implement, but
they weren't done.
So not only do we have lies being told now
to cover the fact that this has nothing to
do with wind farms, we also have the negligence
of a decade to fix a lot of these issues.
Other states have done this stuff like this
isn't it's not rocket science.
It's climate science.
I guess it's really just basic engineering
generators can be prepared for winter.
A lot of this stuff relates to adequately
insulating and in other ways maintaining different
instruments at new.
Lear natural gas, as well as coal plants,
there was a list, I mean, look at the report.
The report is not exactly exciting reading,
but the report makes it clear what needs to
be done.
In some cases, its valves.
I mean, this is not important stuff.
It actually reminded me of the Deepwater Horizon
oil spill in the Gulf where a 500000 dollar,
some kind of I believe it was a gasket or
a valve or something like that.
A hundred thousand dollar modification, 500000
to each of these drilling platforms could
have prevented.
What ultimately was I mean, was it was it
hundreds of millions?
I don't even remember at this point for BP
what the total damages were, the environmental
damage, et cetera.
This this reminds me of that in many ways.
Also, by the way, even since 2011, it's not
like this happened in Texas in 2011 and then
not for a decade.
And then now it happened again and they opted
not to do anything.
This has actually happened to lesser degrees
over the last decade, and Texas still didn't
deal with it.
So is anybody going to be held accountable?
Someone should be.
The party that's in charge in Texas is the
party that claims to be about personal responsibility.
We'll talk about one Texas mayor who resigned
in the last few days after making some insane
comments about so-called lazy Texans, the
people that had lost power, I guess that sort
of personal responsibility.
But there needs to be responsibility and accountability
at a greater level here.
I don't know that there's an appetite for
it, but it's going to happen again.
We have an immediate tragedy.
We shouldn't ignore that.
There are people lacking power right now.
But once that's fixed, what is going to be
done, because this is a real problem and it's
one where solutions have been outlined, they've
been sitting around, you know, the Trump administration
had the pandemic response playbook.
They ignored it.
These recommendations have been sitting around
Texas for a decade.
And now look at the tragedy that is taking
place.
So we'll continue telling the truth about
the role of different types of energy in this.
And if you've fallen for the Tucker Carlson,
Greg Abbott or whoever else Fox and Friends
line of this is what happens under the Green
New Deal and renewable energy.
That's not true.
But ultimately, someone has to be held accountable
for this.
Let me know who you think it should be.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman